esta es una fuente de alimentación
conmutada de un reproductor de dvd la
fuente de alimentación conmutada opera a
una frecuencia alta mientras que las
frecuencias de alimentación lineales
operan a frecuencias más bajas también
hay otras diferencias clave por ejemplo
las fuentes de alimentación conmutadas
suelen ser más pequeñas producen mayor
interferencia electromagnética por lo
que tienen más filtros prat más operan
de manera más eficiente pueden cambiar
la cantidad de energía que suministra y
por lo tanto no utilizan tanta energía
como una fuente de alimentación lineal
así que bueno estas son las principales
diferencias que tienen y bueno ahora
podrán ver que por aquí es donde entra
la energía observa que hay un fusible y
este fusible es para proteger de
cualquier falla en la placa si hay una
falla en la placa el fusible se fundirá
el condensador de seguridad también está
diseñado para fallar en caso de un
cortocircuito por lo tanto tiene estas
marcas en el para la regulación está
básicamente diseñado para fallar si hay
corté una placa y proteger en caso de
que haya algún problema ahora bien tanto
las bobinas de inducción como este
condensador que tenemos aquí son usados
para filtrar el ruido de la fuente de
alimentación la fuente de alimentación
funciona a una frecuencia alta por lo
tanto produce ruidos y éstos evitan que
el ruido vaya de vuelta a la casa y que
hacen otros problemas en la línea ahora
si ven aquí hay cuatro diodos los diodos
evitan el flujo de corriente en una sola
dirección actúan como una válvula
eléctrica así que los cuatro diodos
están puestos allí para actuar como un
puente rectificador y toman la corriente
que entra la cual es corriente alterna y
la convierten en corriente continua así
que déjame traer estas hojas por aquí
para mostrarles un poco lo que les estoy
diciendo observen la energía normalmente
entra así es una onda de corriente
alterna una onda senoidal y nosotros
queremos que la energía fluya en línea
recta que es corriente directa
así que la corriente alterna básicamente
fluye en una dirección y después cambian
y fluyen en otra dirección así que van
justo así y queremos convertirla en
corriente continua así que esos cuatro
diodos la convierten en corriente
continua lo que quiere decir que
básicamente voltean la onda justo así y
después la energía sólo fluye en una
dirección y ese es un aspecto clave así
que vamos a regresar a observar algunos
otros componentes por aquí tenemos esta
resistencia esta resistencia ayuda a la
placa en la detección de corriente y
luego por aquí tenemos dos capacitores
que son básicamente parte del filtro de
interferencia electromagnética y ayudan
a limpiar el voltaje para ese propósito
por acá es un transformador y es un
transformador de alta frecuencia para
que un transformador funcione debe de
haber un cambio en el voltaje así que
básicamente en la manera en la que
hacemos el cambio de voltaje es hacer
álbum llamado modulación por ancho de
pulso el voltaje para salir de esta
manera déjame ponerlo aquí y crea una
onda cuadrada esto de aquí es corriente
continua y esto de por acá es energía al
100%
este es el cero y está cambiando de
encendido apagado y cambia muy rápido
ese cambio de encendido apagado permite
que la inducción pase y eso es lo que
ocurre al interior de este transformador
el transformador disminuye el voltaje de
120 volts a 12 volts y 5 volts y bueno
ahora la modulación por ancho de pulso o
la onda cuadrada está siendo regulada
por este chip de kim el cual es un
circuito integrado que controla el p w
en la modulación por
de pulso y bueno pueden ver por aquí que
hay un montón de resistencias lo más
probable es que sirvan para proteger al
circuito integrado y además tenemos
algunos diodos para controlar el flujo
de corriente él optó acoplador es usado
para probar el voltaje de salida y
regularlo durante básicamente en
condiciones de carga y este tipo de aquí
parece un tránsito pero realmente es un
regulador de derivación que básicamente
funciona como un diodo tener un diodo cn
variable un diodo sener es una tarjeta
que fluye en una dirección hasta un
cierto punto y después por encima de un
cierto punto lo que permite que la
corriente fluya en ambas direcciones
estas son las funciones de un diodo se
en el variable y bueno para finalizar
quiero agradecer a don tu pro quien me
dio una excelente retroalimentación en
el primer vídeo y me sirvió mucho de
cómo funcionan las fuentes de
alimentación reguladas o las fuentes de
alimentación conmutada